Oh
thank you very much for coming I'm
really excited to be here
the stock I'm going to talk about the
Semantic Web in Python I'm really
excited to make the stock because
actually the the guys who are involved
in this field usually that they used to
love with Java is stuff like that
because a few years ago this kind of
stuff were made mainly in the Java
language but nowadays there are many
solutions that you may use for your
Python code very few words about me I
got a PhD in computer science in the
University of Naples last year now I'm a
postdoc researcher at the University of
Salerno I'm so I come from hilly I love
data science and all the the topics
related to this kind of stuff and the
other half of me is a game guy so we may
talk about any of the funny things we
usually love okay some very briefly
keywords about the things I'm interested
in I usually work in with information
retrieval stuff Marshall learning and
recently for my postdoc with link and
data and Semantic Web so that is the
topic of the talk today and I usually
work with this kind of stuff in Python I
mainly used all these tools so for
instance Network X knew by sight by a
lot so I can learn from my master in
encode and gem Tim for topic modeling
and audio flip for semantic data so
actually this talk is mainly based on
our the RDF lab wants you to make you a
brief presentation of the main features
of this great package so the talk is
semantic web master link data with
Python so the first thing I would like
to talk about is the web okay I don't
know many of you are already aware that
researcher and the
formation retrieval or web analysis
estimated that the shape of the web is
like a bowtie okay actually the web
graph is composed by a core which is the
main part which is also known as this
strongly connected component that's the
core of the web where all the pages link
each others okay and then there are four
on the left of the origin regions that
contains the the pages and the resources
in the web that link to the core two
pages in the core and the termination
region that contains pages that are
linked to the pages linked to by the
pages in the core just to make very few
estimation of the size of this parts the
core contains almost the 30% of the web
the Alpha regions contains all the open
contain almost the 25% of the whole web
and there are three is at 22 percent of
this connected page this is of course an
estimation for instance how can you
reach the origin region if no page links
to them okay this is just an estimation
anyway from a knowledge management point
of view the www so the world wide web is
full of data and actually the data are
usually published in different formats
they may be available in PDF and th and
teeth as for images or text files and
all these pages all these resources can
be linked to or by HTML pages okay or
other documents in general so these kind
of resources of the data that you can
link to in the web page in the web graph
okay but this kind of approach has some
limitations first of all the data format
is for human consumption is mainly
supposed to be for human consumption and
the the different formats available on
the resources on the web require
specialized algorithms and tools to
access the resources search for the
reserves
and we use the data so this is when and
why Lincoln data comes into play
Lincoln did refers to a set of
principles and usually best practices
for publishing and connecting structured
data on the web and all the principles
and best practices best practices are
mainly guided by w3c standards and
recommendations actually the link data
model is basically founded on that on
the basis of the www resource model
every resource is uniquely identified by
a URI which stands for universal
resource identifier and there are all
the resources in this graph are
interconnected by other links ok so this
is the basic model of the resources in
the linker data and there is a so called
five stars principles principle in order
to do to understand if the data you're
publishing to the web is a linked data
you got one star if the data is
available on the web in whatever format
you may have two stars if the data are
available on the web but in a machine
readable and structured format
you've got three stars if the data are
is available in a no proprietary format
forced us if the data is published and
using open data standards and finally
you are the best one so you have five
stars if all the above stars apply plus
links to other data in the same formats
okay some very brief access simple
examples the like button on Facebook
actually and that's under the hood a
somesome link did some semantic web data
in a format which is called rdfa we will
talk about that briefly in
next slides or for instance a very
famous project which is called dbpedia
which is a sort of transformation of the
textual data coming from text from
Wikipedia in a linked data format okay
just to make an example how this kind of
stuff I really used in practice if you
consider the Wikipedia page about the
Python in this case since the animal
this page has been transformed in the
dbpedia standard okay the DPP storage so
the format of this page is structured in
some in some way I will not go into the
details so this link will correspond to
this one on the on dbpedia okay and then
the dbpedia here contains some
semantical information about the content
of this page and the BBC nature section
actually exploits this kind of
information in order to categorize the
pages about animals in this in this
website in this case the python is under
the reptile actually it is almost
unreadable sorry for this but here it is
reptile and the BBC nature's website
exploits the dbpedia stuff to know that
the Python a Python is a reptile okay
and this correspond actually to this
kind of this is called schema semantic
schema where you have a set of different
terms you may look on and in this case
the class of this animal correspond to
the reptile okay this is just a very
simple example linker data in the web
actually in 2007 this is almost this was
almost the situation of the linker data
in 2008 this is the graph the snapshot
of the linker data available on the web
this is in 2009 and this is a snapshot
of the linker data in
2011 okay so every day new formats come
and new link a day to come in the
repository this is actually the main
idea of the linker data a very huge
graph of resources interconnected each
other okay so here we go to this
semantic part the Semantic Web is very
famous I guess is based on some
principles this according to Tim
berners-lee who here's the creator of
the world wide web and one of the first
supporter for this kind of techniques
the Semantic Web is a system that
enables machine to understand and
respond to complex human requests based
on their meaning that's why it is
semantic park and from a practical point
of view the Semantic Web is built upon a
set of standards and best practices the
so-called standard stack is composed by
under the hood by the URI which is the
the structure the basis on which every
single resource can be uniquely
identified on top of it there is the RDF
and then the others the other levels
though the other layers of this stack up
to the the proof and the trust one okay
indeed the these are some details the
URI and the Unicode are in the basis of
this stack and then we have the XML
syntax in general the RDF which is the
resource description framework we are
going to talk about in details in the
next slide and then all the things that
are that exploits this kind of data
model for semantic data representation
and this is the final aim so to have a
sort of machine transactions machine
interactions you exploiting this kind of
data so an algorithm with this kind of
data should be able to automatically
understand the meaning and so making
some decision about them ok the audio F
stands for your sauce description
framework actually it is not a data
format RDF is a data model to express
relationships between arbitrary data
element RDF files can be utilized in
multiple formats the total on three or
RDF XML and these files can be stored in
this civilized version of the RDF can be
stored in files or databases also known
as tribal stores the name comes by the
model of the data so in the RDF the RDF
data model is basically a graph based
model okay so we have a set of triples
where we have a subject predicate and an
object and we end up with all the data
represented with a set of different
tribals in general all the try all the
elements in the tribals are referred as
resources ok so we talk about resources
when we deal with our RDF data and all
the resources are identified by unique
your I references that are usually
referred at your i-raths the main
difference between your URI and URLs is
that the urls are the just a way to link
and to reference some de s or to link to
some data URI is instead a way to
uniquely identify a single resource on
the web the the RDF model also allows
for blank notes in the case so also
known as anonymous notes anonymous notes
in case you don't know the URI of the
things you would to reference let me it
may happen actually so we end up with
this kind of graph for instance we have
a blank note here with this different
set of attributes and links so we have
in this case a blank note that has first
name John second name doe weblog this
weblog and then this blank note knows
these other guy here which is another
blank note that it has Steven Taylor as
first name as email this TBA at medCom
okay it's just for example verse equal 1
and finally the data model also allow
for a literally literal values some
examples are this ones and they litter
balance may also and may optionally have
the language reference or the type
reference for instance if you're you're
talking about a weblog or a Wikipedia
page you may have the same page in
different languages and that's the case
when the language attribute comes in
entry fly very few words about the
serialization formats rdf allows for
very different civilization formats they
are very useful for the reuse of the
data they are the entry polls the uh
three RDF XML rdfa and the RDF jason
just to mention the very famous ones the
first one the entrar polls is the very
simple format and it's very readable for
human readable n3 is simple as well but
it's more compact rdf is a classical
representation of this kind of data and
it is the original w3c recommendation
about this rdf is a compact way to
represent RDF data and is very integral
to other formats such as X HTML pages
and finally the RDF JSON format which is
useful in case of restful api so look
let's make some examples in this case we
get the dbpedia page the dbpedia
representation of the Python programmer
language page on Wikipedia okay Libby
PDM shows you a set of structured
information about the Python programming
language in this case we have dbpedia l
WL which is the prefix for it's just a
prefix designer that is we'd open resume
developer Python Software Foundation
influences boo programming language
Cobra programming language d e f sharp
and so forth okay the main the most
important thing here is that every
single value in the in this page is
actually a reference to any two other
resources
okay this is what I meant when I talk to
we talked about link and data okay so
these data in n-triples format is it
sorry okay this is a chain the end
tribals format is just like this it's in
tribals is the simple representation and
the most human readable we have the
subject the object the Prada predicate
here the property and the object and we
end up with all the different tribals in
our data set we usually have some prefix
s in just you to allow for references to
the meaning of the different of the
different reference and that's it so
it's very simple every tribal hands with
a with the . so it that's it
the n3 representation is a more compact
representation
it basically avoids the repetitions the
duplications
it's just exactly the same apart from
that every repetition is avoided and is
substituted by a comma so we may a list
of elements that having the same prefix
or the same property and finally the RDF
acts and
representation is an XML representation
of the data so we may structure the data
as an XML resource and then we have more
verbis in a more structured
representation must mostly intended for
algorithms and for processing not for
reading okay for human reading I mean
and finally the last important things to
say is that RDF comes with different
vocabularies but the vocabulary for an
idea faces the finite set of predicates
so when you want to know how are which
are the the predicates you you're going
to use for to describe your resources
the vocabularies is the things you're
going to use because the vocabularies
defines the set of properties you might
use to link the subjects and the objects
in your data there are many different
vocabularies some of them are the c ox
that stands for semantically interlink
at online communities so this is a
vocabulary for online communities the
fourth vocabulary which stands for
friend of a friend or cabbage actually
this schema this vocabulary is by
Facebook okay and this cause vocabulary
that stands for simple knowledge
organization schema these are just two
very few vocab there are many of them
actually in the link adage where they
are very there is a huge set of these
vocabularies differentiated by the
intended use and the domain that refers
to okay in particular shock forth and
scores are interconnected so this is a
very brilliant example of interconnected
data and linker data in fact we have a
fourth person here that it corresponds
to a user in the shock in the SIOC
schema and for instance the user creates
some
blog posts that are related to the
concepts and these concepts have been
described in a scause schema okay this
is just a very simple example of
interconnected data interconnected data
formats okay we will dive into these
examples in the few slides with Python
code so how do we query the data
represented in RDF we use a language
which is called SPARQL that stands for
simple protocol and RDF creole language
and it's the standard query language for
idea graphs
SPARQL attempts to match patterns in the
graph so it is a patterns based query
language and it binds wild color
variables to find a solution just to
make some examples in the formal example
we select all the predicates and the
objects coming from the dbpedia
resources referring to the Python Python
programming language in the second
example we want to get the abstract of
the Python coming from dbpedia
that filters only the language which is
English in this case and find the last
examples we in the last example we want
to get all the list we we call the Union
here I don't know if you can read this
we call the Union operator in the SPARQL
language and we get the list of all the
the languages that a Python influences
and all the languages that python has
been interested by okay we get all these
data honest it's very simple to SQL
language okay but the difference is that
SPARQL is able to make queries on data
represented you know in the RDF format
so we finally end up with the last part
of the presentation which is about the
mastering linker data with Python so I
guess this should be the most funny part
of the this talk the
the Python solution to tame the Semantic
Web is mainly based on idea on the RDF
flip
other flip is a great package is a
brewery great library that keeps on
improving and extend its functionality
if you want to import it you write
import idea flip audio flip has a
built-in object which is called graph
the graph is or the in this case a
conjunctive conjunctive graph but it's a
graph and I will only details about it
so we create a graph here then we make
parts a single resource in represented
in the end tribals format so in the past
method of the graphs allows an
additional parameter that tells the
audio flip which is the format of the
our defib yes I'm sorry I got didn't get
your boy maybe yes yes I guess so yeah
yeah thank you
then we so the post method get these
these RDF files in the in memory and
then we increase the the RDF graph and
then we may I - right on the tribals of
this graph with with in singles for
instruction then we may list all the
tribals that matches for instance the
very simple query on the graph we get
all the tribals and matches this sort of
query so we get all the resources that
have the RDF about properties no matter
which is the subject or the object okay
we may also manipulate the graph so we
may
add additional notes and trifles in
particular to this so we had two notes
and link between them to to the graph
and then we may finally text or and save
the graded resulting graph in a
serialized format in this case we see
utilize the graph in a pretty XML
version okay
and that's it very very simple
ODF can be extended with persistence
support actually there are many projects
supporting the persistent so there is a
DF Lib CQ light for a CQ light
persistent PostgreSQL so DB for soap
databases MySQL RDF Jason Parsons
utilizar leveldb and spark else or for
general tribal source and rdf:li SQL
alchemy that allows you to deal with RDF
data model in a more o RM oriented way
just to make an example about the RDF
lab SQLite here we invoke the plug-in
model here the plugin for SQL store so
we create this file okay and then we
start to create a graph so we add these
two namespaces these are the namespaces
of dbpedia then we add two different
triples to these graphs and then we we
civilize the data and commit the
civilized version of the data to the
data store so this graphs has been saved
in the RDF - test dot TS which is a CQ
light database and finally we load the
data we've been a few lines of Python we
again get the plug-in this is supposed
to run in two different
Python shells so we get again the the
SQL plug-in we open the file then we
create the graph and serialize the graph
directly from the store okay for example
one of the greatest feature of RDF lib
is that it it embeds SPARQL
functionality so you may query
your model you may query your data
directly using SPARQL there is a SPARQL
library in the plugins modal and in
particular in this particular example
we're going to use a prepare query which
is a sort of template query so we
prepare the the SPARQL query here in
this case we want we are interested in
getting the object that a general
language has been influenced has
influenced it okay and we initialize the
namespace here telling to the query
enter the query engine that the dbpedia
prefix corresponds actually to this URL
the URI this is just a shortcut to make
the same text more readable okay it's
not actually needed is just a shortcut
to make to allow for a very simple query
both in writing and reading mode so
finally we get the graphs so we get the
from dbpedia the graph corresponding to
all the programming language and then we
query for the set of languages that
python in this case because language
here the image binding parameter allows
to substitute the variable language that
is the one the one guy here with python
and python is the object corresponding
is this one is the object corresponding
to this URI
okay so we're referring precisely the
Python programming language in the
dbpedia storage and then we substitute
the the variable language to the python
so we are looking to the set of
languages that python influenced okay so
far so good said ok ok so let's see the
other flip in action and in particular
we're going to to see an example that
exploits the social social network
analysis I'm sorry and in particular the
semantic social web network analysis
we're going to work with these three RDF
vocabularies in particular this is these
are the data we are going to use as for
the fourth schema so the
friend-of-a-friend schema the
friend-of-a-friend schema is used to
represent the social network okay
the friend-of-a-friend schema contains
the fourth nose which is the relation
that you may use to interlink to
different person to different people two
people in the in your network so you
have here the node corresponding to Tim
berners-lee this is the unique reference
to this guy this god this node here has
a fourth name corresponding to Tim
berners-lee that is this one here okay
then we know that Tim berners-lee the
guy here knows with the fourth nose
relation knows other guys for instance
the John Mark of and we reference the
node of the person know by Tim
berners-lee by he's unique reference
okay and this is a graphical
representation for the this RDF in the
XML version then we have this cost data
this cost data are used to represent a
taxonomy of different concepts so we
have a set of concept and in particular
we exploit the two properties of this
closed bubble which are this cocinero
and this cost brother in this case we
are able to specify which is the
relation among different topics okay so
in this case we have knowledge
representation and the knowledge
presentation corresponds to artificial
intelligence that is a broader concept
of artificial intelligence and it is
narrow with respect to the description
logic it's just an example okay so in
this case we are able to set a taxonomy
of different concepts and we want to
exploit this
sure combining all the information in
the final silk model okay so the
semantically interconnected online
community vocabulary we have here a blog
post the blog post has a title for
instance that in this example is name
title but it's this file there actually
is the lower bits and stuff like that
every single blog post as an as a
creator thanks to the shark has--
creator property the as creator property
correspond to a fourth person and in
this case the creator should be for
instance d berners-lee the guy in the
previous slides and every blog may have
a set of different shock topics and the
shock topic associate to a blog a set of
Scott's concepts okay so this is example
we use to interconnect the different
data in the different data formats so we
want to apply social network analysis we
are interested in for instance know who
are the most connected people who are
the most influential people who where
are the cliques in the graphs and we're
going to use the network X library which
is a powerful library Python to to to
make this kind of stuff we start by
loading and passing the graph okay so
really create the graph here and then we
we pass the fourth graph and this cost
graph in very few lines because rdf:li
already embeds the namespaces for the
fourth and discuss vocabulary because
they are very very famous burry they're
mostly used by in many cases and so we
are not required to write a lot of code
because we import the namespaces so this
guy here and already and that's the
reference to the URL of the schema and
that's it so we create two different
graphs for the two formats for the as
for the shocked audio file we need to
write a summer code because this kind of
schema is not provided out of the box by
the audio flip so we
create the RDF names we import the RDF
namespace we inject in the graph these
two namespaces this one is for the shock
this other one here is for another
namespace user in the data which is
called Dublin core this dublin core
schema is basically used for bible
graphic information so in case you work
with I don't know
documents and stuff like that usually
this kind of data are represented by
means of the dublin core and then we
create graph we build all the namespaces
to these graphs and then we pass the
chakra file okay very simple so we build
the social graph here so we after we
have all the graphs we merge the RDF
graph and then we queried the graph with
the SPARQL query in this case we want to
get all the nicknames of the the you end
the the couple the the yes the couples
of users and nicknames corresponding to
the fourth niek attribute in the data
forth correspond to the fourth namespace
in RDF correspond to the audience
FS namespaces and then we get the
nicknames corresponding to the ID and an
EQ we added this as a string then then
we build a network express of
relationships we import Network X we
create in this case a graph which is a
network X graph we query the model
getting all the users and the so the
subject and the objects of our data
corresponding to the fourth knows
relation and we make an edge in this
graph connecting node a to be because
they know in our RDF network represented
so we have the network X graph we may
find the clique with this graph because
now an ax and X graph is a network X
graph so we look for the different
clique
is and it's very simple because a
network already embed a method to this I
click by the way all is it's a sub grab
sub graph where all the vertices of our
connected component and we may also
interested in calculating the centrality
of every node in this case we're going
to use the between the centrality
between the centrality is one of the
metric or almost use it and very famous
usually used in social network analysis
between the centrality corresponds to
the number of shortest paths from all
the vertices to to the others that pass
through that node so in this case we
calculate the between us and try to do
all the graph and then we get the most
connected guy in our network by sorting
by the score here so we sort the list of
scores getting by the betweenness
centrality and we get the results very
simple if this is network X the RDF was
just in the previous part just to load
the data for the graph we're going to
analyze so that's it for Network X but
what about the RDF and why and how we
might improve the analysis and exploits
the fact that we are dealing with linked
data and the RDF data a very simple
example should be this one we may extend
the network of friends thanks to the
leveraging on the SPARQL flexibility in
traversing the relations in the graph in
particular the most important part here
in this query is this one because in
this query we are going to look for the
common friends of these two guys here
Tim berners-lee and John Cage with this
query we are able to get all the common
friends but the most important part here
is this one because as SPARQL allows to
set this operator with this property
which is the the plus sign here that
tells the
SPARQL engine to traverse the relation
recursively okay so out of the box this
means that the roof off knows relations
among these two guys is recursively
repeated and so he starts here to
traverse the connected component
starting from those those nodes and a
more very complicated example is this
one that tries to exploit the
interconnected data in particular if you
can remember we have a set of users in
the network we have a set of concepts
and we add we have a set of blog posts
that are being authored by users in our
network and every every blog post is
associated to a concept with this query
almost complicated
I guess we're trying to select a
different we're going to select authors
here will I try to make that simple the
basic idea is will we are looking for
given a user in this case the target
user is team Li the target user is used
here okay so we look for all the other
users so this is the filter so it may be
simple to do to start with this part we
are filtering all the users in the
network that are not that that does not
correspond to the author we're looking
for and the two guys don't already know
each other
so we look for authors that have been
horrid blog posts that whose set of
topics is almost related to the set of
topics are the target user already did
and this is the the
in this this point
ah because we have the set of concepts
of the 2d so we have the target user we
have the set of past of the target user
and here we have the set of concepts
associated to the top the blog post of
the target user and so we look for the
set of related concepts to this set of
topics in particular the the narrower
the broader topics okay and then we look
for other blog posts authored by
different users that I that the target
user doesn't know already whose concept
to respond to a broader version on our
version of the target topic I really
hope that I've been clear if not please
ask there's no problem so the last light
what's next actually we missed oh sorry
actually we made some parts so the
Duryea see the other layers for the
semantic web stack in particular RDF lab
and that's other libraries to deal with
the rest of the Semantic Web parts for
instance the Oh W hell RL which is a
project that allows RDF lab to integrate
the are L stands for Roo language so
allow us to integrate rule language to
make the inference on the Oh W health
data and finally there is the fushia
reasoner which is an engine that takes
all the semantic data and is able to
make reasoning it's basically related to
description logic and rule languages
over there and uses fukuchi is a reason
that allows you infer new information so
get the Semantic Web get the semantic
representation of your data and tries to
derive new information
considering that kind of stuff and
finally the Python 3 support of the RDF
lab keeps improving that's a great
feature I guess finally some suggested
readings there's two
books are very nice very well-written
this is about spiky well in general this
is about Python for the Semantic Web and
there these two books are very useful
especially for those of you are never
worked with this kind of stuff so thank
you very much for a kind attention
thanks for their you oh yeah see a
couple of questions
afraid to me again
just one questions are the queries that
you present seem quite complex can you
give any indication on how much does it
scale to well be a Wikipedia yeah
actually I have to yeah I try to okay
this one yep yes okay actually the
scalability problem is a very nice topic
so thank for asking the data
I used to test this query were very
small so and all the processing were
allowed to run in memory actually in
that case I didn't use any persistent
plugin for the Edit flip so all the
processing have been run in memory
directly in memory but in the general
case this is the drawback of this kind
approach because it's based on graph
processing so usually in real cases this
data are stowed in a set of inner data
source in database engines that are
called tribal source there is just one I
can remember which is called Allegro I
guess which is Python friendly so you
may use this kind of technique to this
kind of system to store your data in RDF
and so Gibbs
so give to to that system all the
Bourdon to make the the processing and
returning you the results now just a
follow up and see as a plugin that you
mentioned so see I'm I'm sequel alchemy
easy
ODP plugins they don't really support a
query language them it's more just lets
a programmatic access actually all the
plugins refers to despite pure language
but I don't yeah so is that what you're
referring to
I think we're getting things this one so
do this as a pod Sparkle or oh this one
is just to have our idea flip to link to
some trifle source in general it's very
general-purpose this one SQL alchemy
tries to improve the performance of the
rdf:li SQL a SPARQL model module because
every time you make a query with the
built in module you hit the memory every
time every time with this SQL alchemy
there is there are some abstractions so
you may see you may apply some memory of
improvements so in order to reduce the
amount of memory required to make the
processing and the other cases these are
just this one is very useful I never had
the chance to to test it but I guess
that it I love PostgreSQL so it's maybe
could be a good chance to to integrate
this kind of data in the urn that
database system thank you very much
thank you for asking
yeah well I had a similar question it
was about how you do it
query when you have a very big data set
which but then maybe another question in
a way to query this language in a more
pythonic way because it's funny funny
yeah this is exactly what the goal of
the SQL oxygen project because and in
this case you're basically writing
SPARQL code in your Python code just
like as you would do in K so at general
as SQL okay so for relational databases
the SQL alchemy tries to
to abstract some object-oriented you
know some object-oriented way all the
stuff and try to apply the the query in
that way but I never use it action then
another thing which I've in the same
method is how so everyone can basically
define their own language like Facebook
define their own predicates and then
someone find their own and then it's
letter standards amount to know what
should be a predicate okay actually the
predicate depends on the schema okay so
every time you define a schema you
define a set of predicates every
predicate correspond to a for a data
format that usually becomes a
recommendation after some revisions by
the w3c consortium so you create your
schema you define your set of properties
and your set of allowed relations for
your data than you and the best way you
can do it is try to integrate other
existing schema in order to support the
linker data a world enjoyable okay thank
you okay okay there are no more
questions um thanks again and everybody
enjoyed the lunch
you